hallo leute ich jetzt wieder eure mal
wanne und willkommen zu sommerloch
nummer
ja ich weiß es ist schon wieder juli und
der sommer seien schon fast vorbei und
der winter steht schon hier dahinten
bereit hallo winter bleibt man noch mit
hinweg ich nämlich immer noch ok
trotzdem habe ich mega bock auf das
sommerloch und es geht auch los mit
neuen formaten eigenen formaten formate
tomate viel spaß kommen wir zu meinem
lieblings netzfilter zurzeit ist mein
lieblings väter aufs netz einfach die
biene
kommen wir nun zu den geschichten aus
der youtube bay ich habe es zwar schon
getwittert aber es hat mich so
frustriert dass ein tag nach dem
anschlag in nizza akkurat seien bomben
prank nicht runter genommen hat
allgemein zu der zeit in der wir jetzt
gerade jetzt gerade leben sind bomben
punks nicht witzig ich glaube es war zu
keiner zeit witzig aber zur jetzigen
zeit darfst du es nicht machen und wenn
dann ein anschlag wie auf mütze denn
wenn das passiert dann musst du dieses
video sofort runter nehmen da gibt es
keine entschuldigung nichts er hat darum
ein entschuldigungs video macht was ich
gar nicht gesehen aber wir auf diesem
festival waren und es war alles nur
scheiß promo um seinen musikvideo am
sonntag zu pushen dass er wieder
geheiratet wird weil er ist ja die
meistgehasste person in deutschland so
wie er sich selber bezeichnet jeder soll
das recht auf meinungsfreiheit haben
jeder sollen youtube channel aufmachen
können und da posten wasser möchte aber
dieser idiot treibt es wirklich soweit
und diese respektlosigkeit dass du nicht
verstehst wenn etwas wirklich ernst ist
und gerade etwas wirklich schlimmes
passiert und menschen angst haben für
deine scheiss promo zwecke die das video
macht und drin lässt das weiß ich ganz
genau dass es deswegen war ich finde das
einfach so scheiße und gibt ihm echt
keine bühne mehr dieser typ der gehört
bestraft dieser typ geld einfach hinter
gittern meiner meinung nach
das ist einfach kannst es nicht machen
du kannst das einfach nicht machen und
jetzt möchte ich irgendwas lustiger
kommen wir nun zu meinen lieblings ganz
kurz und knackig es ist kein freund von
robin und zwar nimmt mich dieser song
immer so richtig mit kommen wir nun zum
wetter in aschgabat der hauptstadt von
turkmenistan wird es diese woche richtig
war und zwar bis zu 42 grad dazu gibt es
leichte wolken und eine
regenwahrscheinlichkeit von zehn prozent
also wenn das war nicht hitzefrei
bedeutet obwohl in deutschland wärst du
als kawata habt ihr bei diesem wetter
hitzefrei oder nicht schreibt in die
kommentare das wetter wurde ihnen
präsentiert von katzen im taucheranzügen
favoriten ich muss vorweg sagen dass bei
meinen favoriten nur serien drin sind
und ich einfach nicht anderes gefunden
wo ich jetzt sagen würde haye das
benutze ich oft das mag ich gerade super
gerne it markt gerade am liebsten
einfach serien kommen wir zu meinem
ersten favoriten eine serie community
den meisten sagt community bestimmt
etwas es ist eine serie die kommt aus
amerika und die handelt von menschen die
in einem college in einem community
college sind und da so ihren alltag
erleben klingt furchtbar langweilig ist
es aber absolut nicht es gibt allerdings
einen punkt dem aber dieser serie
beachten muss muss die serie auf
englisch gucken wenn du sie auf deutsch
guckst ist sie nicht mehr witzig die
synchronstimmen sind schlecht die witze
sind nicht gut übersetzt und ja nicht
auf deutsch auf englisch und ihr werdet
diese serie liebe mein zweiter favorit
eine serie
ich hatte sich schon mal in einem
sommerloch erwähnt terry bradshaw und
zwar habe ich jetzt die dritte und
letzte staffel zu ende geguckt und diese
serie kriegt von mir fünf von fünf
fingern und damit irgendwas anderes
aussah serien
habe ich hier noch serviettenknödel
lecker serviettenknödel luxor twitter
frage ich aber jetzt gefragt wenn ihr zu
eurem früheren ich über icq etwas
schreiben könnte
was wäre es und das sind eure antworten
es ist nicht cool wenn süße maus sie und
hab dich schlug zu deinem standard
vokabular gehört ich habe eine idee für
ein tolles produkt nennt sich ipod pass
auf worauf sie es lasst die schreib
style
die leute zahlen von letzter woche er
finde ein spiel in der man in der realen
welt rumläuft und pokemon suchspiele so
lange und so oft super lula und slider
lama wie du kannst denn irgendwann gibt
es das nicht mehr
du wirst deine nummer ein leben lang
auswendig kennt niemand interessiert
sich für den emotionalen songtext status
gatorade ich würde mir nichts schreiben
ich würde mir eine einladung zu dem
spiel schicken
machen wir weiter mit unseren topf 3
heute habe ich für euch die pop die
potter habe ich für euch die top 3
podcast platz nummer drei der podcast
von change 1000 ist einer der ältesten
youtuber und damit meine ich jetzt nicht
älteste vom alter her sondern einer der
ersten bekannten youtuber auf youtube
früher wissen ab und zu mal angeschaut
haben aber sich so gefeiert heute für
dich seine videos mega gut denn er
probiert essen aus und
er ist einfach er und das macht super
spaß ihm zuzugucken und der hat jetzt
auch so ein podcast der richtig witzig
ist denn chains nimmt kein blatt vorm
mund und das für dich gut
platz zwei geht für mich an fest und
flauschig mit olli schulz und jan
böhmermann gehören sie meistens an wenn
wir in eine längere autofahrt vor uns
haben und dann ballern wir uns so drei
stunden lang mit diesem podcast zu und
du lachst halt wirklich richtig laut mit
ja platz nummer eins geht natürlich
natürlich natürlich an kultur mit ihren
fünf minuten harry potter podcast aber
dann selber ziehen eine halbe stunde und
ist es gar nicht fünf minuten lang
sie redet in jeder episode über fünf
minuten vom film harry potter und der
stein der weisen fünf minuten harry
potter gebe ich zwei daumen nach oben
und mikey machen wir weiter mit meinem
nächsten format haidu hey du wusstest du
eigentlich schon dass ich jetzt bei
studio einen sitz sich im netzwerk eben
wirklich zufrieden mit dem netzwerk es
gab nur eine vertragsauflösung bisschen
doof fand ich soll jetzt anfangen die
kelly zu reden also erfülle ich jetzt
hier meinen vertrag wir waren auf dem
par
wie man dieses wochenende auf dem par-
roca will festival an der holländischen
grenze
und mit wir meine ich joe kelly re wie
sturm und noch ganz viele andere wenig
mich aber extrem gefreut habe bzw auf
extrem gespannt war
wann case und krapfen ich wurde direkt
ins kalte wasser geschmissen und bin mit
case und klappi in einem auto sieben
stunden zum festival gefahren und der
romand auch dabei hallo roman und
während der fahrt so dass wir angekommen
sind habe ich gemerkt die sind
eigentlich noch viel mehr als die im
internet preisgeben was ich sehr schade
finde ich hab ihn aber auch persönlich
gesagt also wir haben nicht nur für
liefers geredet sondern ich habe mit
denen auch gesprochen so warum sagt ihr
dass über das warum verhaltet ihr euch
so deren antworten ja die sind okay
ich kann damit leben trotzdem für junge
menschen da muss man aufpassen
junge menschen sind sehr beeinflussbar
und nein also man muss wirklich gucken
wie man sich verhält im internet
trotzdem hat das festival super spaß
gemacht also mit sm 70 sind wir da
hingefahren und die hatten uns ein grill
organisiert und zelte und musik und ein
kühlschrank ist dann nicht das perfekte
festival feeling ich weiß aber es war
super
zu sehen
so leute es war mir eine unheimliche
freude dieses video zu drehen und ich
hoffe euch gefällt es wenn ja gibt den
daumen nach oben und wir sehen es beim
nächsten mal tschüss